so welcome to the bustling metropolis of
my hometown this is Keynsham population
about 1215 thousand people now I'm here
and you're here with me because well
I seem to blog line stations I've
noticed I'm here to get a train
Christopher London but this time going
off to the sea Cheever event at Google
HQ starts at least one really knows I'm
staying over in London with a friend we
should be kind of fun
all right now
if you're wondering about my eye by the
way I just woke up the other day and it
was really so low I'm like my eyelids
just in time meeting loads of you cheap
isn't going holiday hey Transport for
London tells me that this place reviews
the stairway to maybe used an emergency
can there are 193 steps
well that was crazy than I thought it
would be
London is an office so speaking of which
this one I made an afternoon evening
even think oh now I'm on your hands what
might well yeah about that we'll try and
get you into a massage Belsize Park you
seem to hate your visa into them yeah
I'm not really off to go there this man
however he was Franck agent rossabi he
was born to live in London you have you
had gold running do I tell you in
Lannister pretty sure you shouldn't ask
an Oscar you're going the goodkat him
why you know him well is a dad is an
example of you don't have to let your
qualifications define you
I basically managed to talk my way into
you goes into uni decided I didn't pick
the right degree and I talked my way
into changing cause that you need talk
my way through you into a decent job to
which I then did quite well in because I
managed to talk my way through but you
finished up Laura York yes right now
what the qualify for Ayla they now ask
for 3 a's one x time and what do you get
a level sniff acutely lower i got less
than
further their energy requirements if I
want to live laughing but don't follow
my example for example because I how I
managed to get through stuff is probably
I'm gonna have is D so we're playing and
AK more pork so walk more pork I'm
vegetarian bottom line this one slide
are you actually magic yeah for
masteries this has got even nerdier than
I thought a trip to YouTube page people
go hey no vlogging do you want to be in
the vlog as well
woah she be mean okay she has behind I
haven't be single forever yeah he's
gonna die damn boy he got though Canada
back dr. Seuss New York on top but all
the cats out the bag good there's the
face of that is not the face of mercy oh
yes morning so I just had a very comfy
night on that sofa bit kind of safe
surfing Ashley and then we're gonna go
on sheep to Google HQ really excited
that I wouldn't be London without some
rain I also get to do the really
youtuber thing walking down the street
in London
the camera in the Facebook is less
apparent II what all London youtubers do
I was a very artistic Simon's thank you
so come home we know son cloud I make
that type of all the time to be fair so
we just have an alum focus there we go
we just had an awesome session on
channel optimization so looking at
things like optimizing thumbnails
channel are and gave them to engage that
make sure you like this video make sure
you subscribe to my channel leave a
comment below see I learned but now
we've got a break and I'll actually buy
sure we're doing we're doing another
hour session I think on basically how to
be better users which let's face it like
kind of need you I'm thinking about
sustainability and that sort of thing
I'm making sure you don't burn out and
making sure that more so we just
finished our second session we're not
gonna go had lunch and I'm gonna talk to
some of these lovely each others like oh
hey I love walking the entire time are
we we're always sorry but rather than
actually socializing and forming
marginalization buzzes morning I mean
he's talking to himself rather than talk
to me other people here now talking to
the audience
sorry honestly
so to be more social I thought I - detox
so who do I have the honor of it will be
really professional come on what are you
doing
I teach GCC science my physic registry
it's a naturally hopefully quite because
people watching this I think it was a
while ago by yeah I think I just look
past that I'm getting b-roll honestly
right
Oh
and you suffer through Monday but you
fund you own the tongue I mean like
you've made it
you're selling it and it felt really
sweet girl
don't point out right holding the camera
that's it who do we just have holding
the camera from the future so you're a
gardening based channel so completely
different again I'm guarded [ __ ]
Channel but professionally I am a TV
producer and the camera operator all
right also for I'll tend to my feelings
right now doing a workshop on production
stage and your guys sort of level of
production that you feel like you're at
at the moment so hard lights for example
oh I know lights over here so like not
somebody quite important
you see started a company my name is
Federico I found it Carlos hey Oh Ana
which is a site where you can organize
and curate your videos from your channel
YouTube intercourse so it's like giving
a category to any educator which is
something that I'm interested in doing
watch the space in a few weeks because
he was talking about it and I didn't
realize that he was better found if it
comes in and they're like oh okay yeah
hey just something that I needed and I'm
built and turns out a bunch of other
people like ah that's cool I really like
I really do so hopefully I'll be on
there sometime soon so you know watch
out so we just did a session on lighting
which is why I'm so wonderfully lit here
we were experimenting with like
three-point lighting setup I was on the
pill for lighting cellular page who has
been very rude to me in this video so
you should absolutely shouldn't check
out her channel but more importantly
hang on I want some YouTube socks
how how tight about so I found bear like
hello hi how are you know I'd like at
the light of speech I'm Pinterest by day
and I'm here today
if you can't speak so I'll link you I'm
gonna get some because I think some of
my people my subscribers in really
interested music songs between so we're
just doing these forms so we have to
like fill out an ideal collaboration
thing so that's that's in focus there we
go and I just know something very
interesting when it focuses on your face
you are you want to do I'm anaconda off
I run a level revision for nitrogen
videos for any of my students who are
studying SNA to about the subject you
might have and condense all information
which you may have no keeping your
textbook using quite relevant on the
syllabus videos to the BAM energy to try
and understand your that see you so if
you're looking for a revision video
there's a link in the URL and the
description and opted on screen take so
much oh yeah he's only to start it to
give him a subscribe like this is a
really really good content okay I've
just had the geekiest conversation my
life with this man what do you
yeah hi what is that great computer so
the URL for the universe deciding you to
but your baby yeah and we're just
talking about my friends it's been
pretty good so if you're interested in
geeky kid stuff coming come here because
it's all follow me on Twitter at the
violence that's that's him I'll put that
down I'm outside lobsters here so always
be pushing this morning would like the
video subscribe to both like the
playlist missus in oh my god that's such
a behind I know I found Hannah Witton hi
so it just so happens that yeah my
girlfriend sister Alice in myself and to
others I hope you'll really like him I
just yes hey Alice how'd it go in thanks
for watching the video yeah I feel so
privileged there in the middle the funny
he filming me I'm filming with Trent and
Luke uh Roland Carlo Jamie Gary and
Vinny so when you see those videos come
out it's just it's just on a train in
luke's channel okay so look good look
out for those yeah awesome thanks very
much repair thank you I don't mind me
I'm just YouTube my YouTube what our
YouTube in YouTube this is Gary see you
my line i what did you call me
I called you very attractive very chat
Hanson I be movin away I think it was
very attractive and lickable look I'm
I've added that I'm not gonna go okay
that I think that's that's what I've
been called worse this isn't working for
me the whole thing because it I'm sure
they subscribe to you they should say
absolute unto you I mean why should they
subscribe to you three reasons two
reasons one I'm nice enough to I'm doing
good for Albert free he's Gary City I'm
going to do
thank you very much bye okay we had a
droid moving in on Mitch there's some
FaceTime from this panel it's like you
know the episode of community with this
happen
that is accurate regardless of what
you're talkin about
sighs the most Google thing I've ever
seen in my life okay so we just finished
the day really we just had a session on
collaboration that's thought so it looks
like the inside of the page when you're
doing a collaboration on our climate in
fact biology or interacts with algae and
vice versa so one video and her channel
one channel one video online that'll be
happening something I'm probably no
event that we think quite sure yeah I'm
just chilling out here and like you
might recognize this face from some of
the videos that they've done here but
yeah they've cracked health beer and
olives and nibbles and I'm gonna be here
a little bit but thank you for watching
I would say if you haven't got the
message everybody shivery like this
video and subscribe to my channel if you
would like to know fresher and we've
enjoyed come along with me and generally
who I met who's watching this video was
so lovely to meet you you're all of
wonderful bunch of people I really can't
wait to collab with some of you guys
because
I just like to do this for a job I would
really really love to do this for a
video video stuff full-time when I
finish my PhD so give it a year - and
maybe this is all be doing time thanks
for watching this cover stuff makes me
really excited Venus this is why I
became a PhD researcher because science
like this is awesome make incremental
improvements I'm doing battle off going
back to our light clocks this is where
the crucial part comes because the thing
about the speed of light is that its
constants but not any old constant as
can be worked out from the equations
which describe light which is actually
an oscillation of electric and magnetic
fields